uh our meeting to order
and the first thing i'll do is read the
script
as chair of division two of the house
finance committee
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor
as a result of the coven 19 pandemic
in accordance with house rule 67
and the governor's emergency order
number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this public meeting is pertaining to
the merger of in that's outlined in hb2
to for the university system and
the community college system and we will
take up
any other matters relating to the
division
if time permits please note that there
is no
physical location for members of the
public to observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order
i am confirming that members of the
committee
and select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate contemporaneously
during this meeting through the zoo
electronic meeting platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting
by the zoom platform or by telephone all
necessary access
information has been made available in
the house calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules
rsa house rules and rsa 91a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting
should email lba underscore fiscal
at leg.
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
lba staff are on the meeting assist
please note that all votes that are
taken
during this meeting shall be done by
roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone
in the room with you during this meeting
which is required
under the right to know law
representative lynn
if you would call the role please yes
thank you madam chair um representative
porter
here all right and uh
at your home i'm sorry i'm here at home
uh alone in my office but my husband is
in the house
thank you uh representative turcotte
i am in an office in manchester by
myself
thank you representative heath good
morning amir heath here in manchester
i'm at home alone
thank you i'm bob lynn i'm here in
windham
uh my wife is in the house but i'm alone
in the room
uh representative murray good morning
kate murray here in newcastle with the
dog my husband's in the kitchen right
now but he'll be heading downstairs
shortly
thank you uh representative petry
regional petra here in farmington the
wife is roaming around with a dog
as usual thank you and representative
umberger
yes i'm in my home in piersarge and my
husband is out
shoveling the snow and ice that fell off
the roof
but uh he will be in and out so
thank you so thank you uh
i would like to uh welcome uh
catherine provencher and susan hur
hurt is that yeah um shannon
reed joe marone e
is it moroni or maroon
uh you're you're muted marone except
when
we're in italy okay i wasn't sure
and uh yeah and uh
yeah seth fields so today we're going to
um talk about the
um cost saving measures
that the um ccs
and age and the university system
have been um taking
up over the last year
two years five years whatever it is and
um mickey did send
all of the committee members a copy of
both
briefings last evening and
so i would like to if we could start
with
the community college and i'm
not sure who wants to start this
briefing
thank you representative berger good
morning everybody
and i have brought with me as you know
shannon reed who's our legislative
affairs liaison and scott fields who is
our
chief of operations so
we've put together a few slides for you
i'm going to speak
generally and then scott who understands
the numbers is going to speak
specifically about this we wanted to
start off
and talk a little bit about what it is
to be a system
i suspect most of you are familiar with
it but here is the rsa that created
us and i just bring this up because i
want to
point out the language that says a
well-coordinated
system that's a big deal to us along
with our mission
which is to offer technical programming
professional programming
transfers in degrees and certificates
and most recently in short-term training
program over the last couple of years
as you know we have received three
federal apprenticeship grants
and that work has really taught us uh
quite a bit um shannon the next slide
but here's the foundation of how we do
what we do
i mentioned the well coordinated there
are things that happen at our system
office
that essentially free up our seven
colleges
so the system office among other things
provides the payroll side of things the
benefits the grant administration
legal or auditing functions and so on so
that the colleges aren't duplicating
this as you know our colleges range in
size
from institutions that serve
approximately a thousand students to
up to about five thousand uh students
on the credit uh side of the house we're
also structured so that we literally
have one
uh federal income tax number
and all of our collective bargaining
agreements emanate from
the system office they have
representation from people at the
colleges but we have
one collective bargaining agreement for
our full-time faculty
there's another one for our part-time
faculty and a third for our staff but
whether you're at river valley community
college or manchester community college
it's the same collective bargaining
agreement that determines
the work we also house the
administrative structure for programs
that
apply across the state at the system
office running start
is a great example as are all of the
federal
grants that we have as a system
and then finally some of the
other work at the system office has to
do with helping to identify
industry sectors now some of that comes
from how our board is structured
you may know that there are two kinds of
humans on our
board one are folks that are public
members and represent different parts of
the state because we're serving the
entire state
but the other thing that is distinctive
about our board
is that there literally are seats for
the various industry sectors
in our state so there's a health care
seat
an information technology seat two seats
that
are union and trades other seats that
are business and industry
law enforcement and we also have
a voting member from the cte
so that we are fully connected
to the workforce in the state next slide
please
and one of the things that um i think
surprises people
is the age range of students at the
community colleges
22 of our credit population is between
the ages of 16
and 20. but 78 percent of our population
is 21 plus with the bulk of our students
being
25 or older i bring this up because
while we're looking at what's happening
with the demographics of
folks graduating from high school i want
you to see that
much of the work that we do is to serve
the individuals living in our
communities who are quite a ways out of
high school
now this is just the credit side if we
were to bring in
all of the non-credit side the
short-term
training programs we actually would be
even older if you will because the bulk
of our training programs
serve late 20s 30s and early 40s
so we are serving again the residents of
the state
and we do it in a way that people
accommodate people's schedules
as you can see we're more than
two-thirds
part-time students so that means people
are coming and they're taking a couple
of courses
at a time and a small part of our
population is full-time
and in fact that probably represents
quite a bit
of the high school age you know graduate
recent graduates
within our colleges um there hasn't been
a
survey recently but in the past when
we've
essentially asked how many of our
students are working the percentage
exceeds 85 percent
so we are the people who are dealing
with folks who are out working in our
communities
and so their needs uh really determine
how we are structured
you know we're looking at the localness
giving them the opportunity to do their
education
in the communities where they are that
also determines what kind of programming
we have because we're looking at the
industries that supply the jobs for the
regions
that our students live in and what's
important to us
is to give people opportunity so we want
you to start with us
you might want to come back to us again
you might want to transfer
and about twenty percent of our students
transfer upon graduation
within a five year period another ten
percent
transfer so what does that say about us
it says that the bulk of our work is the
work that you created us to
do which is we're serving the technical
and career needs of our area i've i
spoke to you last time and i'll just
underscore that what we're proudest of
is the social mobility
the fact that our students exceed
their parents income by up to
uh by me by an average of
two quintiles so
let me go on the next page shannon
so today we're going to talk about five
areas which we've listed below
to show you what it is that we're doing
in order to be
not only financially sustainable
but to you know spend every penny that
we have
in a conservative and and cost-effective
way
so where i'm going to talk a little bit
about academics and student support
programs
and scott is going to go through our
budgeting practices in i.t
and i'll come back and speak for a
minute about affordability
we put this quote up here this is from a
gentleman named
matt reed who writes a blog confessions
of a community college dean
and he was talking about the fact that
some of the programming or much of the
programming that we do is expensive
because it's equipment intensive or for
instance in the healthcare area
because of the expense in hosting all of
the
the clinical sites and the education
that happens
there and the fact that this is
expensive stuff we're not doing
we are offering social science classes
obviously because that needs to be in
the mix
but the bulk of what we're doing is in
the areas that are listed here the
the industry sectors that you're very
familiar with
next page please
so what are we doing on the academic
side you know once upon a time
our colleges would be looking and they
would each create the programs that were
needed
we realized that that's not an effective
way for us to do business
and i mentioned the lpn program
previously and i'll give you a small
update you know
we had started it at the request of the
home health care
entities throughout the state several
years ago we restarted the program
at river valley and
last year folks in the lakes region said
well
we need more trained
lpns so this january lakes region
began its first class for lpns well
we're under discussion now
the next location is going to be white
mountains community college
now there will come a time when we will
fill
the need for lpns
the the estimate is a little bit less
than 3000 lpns needed
uh for the state and so we'll meet that
need at some point and we'll begin to
fold the program back up and it will go
back to its
home college of river valley and and we
did
you know close the lpn program because
we were listening to industry and the
industry was talking about
magnet hospital status i don't know
that we will rush to that place again
because we
we needed to bring it back up but what
we've learned
is that if we host it at one college we
save money
on the administrative side we have a way
to make sure the programming is up to
date because
we're essentially asking a college to be
a center for excellence
the other thing that we're looking at is
course sharing
one of the things that happened that was
wonderful
from the pandemic is that our faculty
developed
great facility with online learning
tools and we'll be able
to apply that
we have an experiment that was conducted
between white mountains community
college and lakes region
you know when a student i think i talked
a little bit about this last time when a
student is
takes a course at another college the
way that it comes back to their home
college is they'll get the credits but
they don't get the grade
well we've worked with netchie and we're
working with our appropriate
committees within our colleges and that
little program going
on right now which is a pilot for us if
you're a lakes region student and you
take the course at white mountains
not only are you getting the credit but
you're also getting the grade
um this is good for the student because
they have a
a you know a gpa that represents all the
college work that they've done
but it's also good for the employer um
we don't want an employer to have to
sort through five different transcripts
to figure out
how a student did in a particular place
so um i'll call your attention for a
moment as we go through the slides
you'll see that
some of our points are in orange and
these are places where there
are already existing connections with
the
university system of new hampshire
so i talked a little about about program
and course sharing
the orion the realignment you'll see
when you look at our budget
that we tend to build up what we need to
when it aligns with what the industry is
and then when that industry changes or
diminishes we too
change along with that um
i would also on this slide in talking
about academics
talk about the connections that we've
made a few years ago for example
we created some pharmacy technician
training programs and the students who
went through that can sit for a national
certifying
exam but what we needed to do to give
them pathways so that they could
continue
is to look at that non-credit work and
translate it into college credit where
it was applicable
and give them a path so students for
instance who are in a pharmacy
technician program right now and pass
that national test
can apply that to a health science
degree at a couple of our colleges
and receive nine credits for students to
see that they already have a pathway
to college is a really important thing
at this moment
we're seeing a decline in the college
attending
of our high school students you know
approximately 60
percent go on to college well what are
the other 40 percent doing
would they benefit from a non-credit
training program
for assistance in in going into whatever
field it is they want to go into
we'll go on shannon
to student support this has been a huge
issue for us
particularly in the pandemic i just saw
a survey this morning
that compared new hampshire nationally
and based on the survey 16
of students who are going to enroll
in four-year colleges in new hampshire
did not on account of the pandemic but
what is surprising
is it's 43 percent of community colleges
or
students who are going to attend
community colleges
that elected to wait and the two reasons
that they offer
are the pandemic and affordability
well we understand the pandemic piece of
it because our students are the
essential workers
they are the people who are the lnas in
uh healthcare systems they are the
retail people they are the folks
in construction that have added all of
those safety barriers
for all of us so we have been impacted
in a way that
community colleges typically are not
typically
when the economy takes a bit of a
nosedive
enrollment at community colleges soars
because people need to come back
and retrain that's not what's happening
now we do anticipate and we're getting
ready for it
there'll be quite a round of federal
funding coming
as people are able to come back into the
workforce
of particular concern for us right now
are women
because of their uh situation
uh where they're taking care of their
family and their
their children so here we have
you know what are we doing to help what
are we doing to help advise people
and that is we've identified effective
pieces of technology
that increase our uh reach
and we continue to work using various
um career
plans to help students to figure out
what it is that they're going to do and
you have a couple
here listed the mc career coach for
instance that is available
on all of our college websites is a
great place for
students or anyone to figure out what it
is that they want to do
and i'm going to go on to the next slide
and turn you over
to scott who'll talk more about
budgeting and
as we go further we're happy to answer
more questions
so scott if you would take it over
please
if you would my name is scott fields i
am at home
my family is on a different floor and
i'm in intervale new hampshire
what i'm going to talk about this
morning is our sustainability focus and
and what this is is ccsh is a lean
entrepreneurial organization that
thrives on developing increasingly
efficient ways of doing business
you know this nimbleness can be found in
uh throughout our business practices and
some of the examples that we have here
this morning are
you know we're able to leverage what we
call shared services and we have that
centrally that allows us to manage many
things
at the system office level but we also
take that a step further and
we leverage that ability in terms when
there are vacancies across
college campuses so we're able to fill
in spots and
allow bandwidth to absorb where these
vacancies
uh reside a lot of it falls within the
finance area
institutional research which is ir
financial aid
hr help desk and marketing essentially
what will happen is we'll have folks
that may reside in
their home bases in concord but they'll
present
provide financial aid directorship
supervision
at white mountains community college
another example
is in white mountains again i'm still
doing some of their financial functions
while
doing things in concord for the system
office
another way that we look at our
financial sustainability on this is we
do maintain
small levels of reserves at the college
and system office level
to provide a cushion for times of
fiscal stress as opposed to using it to
supplement
ongoing operational costs that we've
seen about in the news
recently in the last couple of years uh
other ways that we
provide this is to ensure that we
continually think outside the box in
terms of how we negotiate contracts
whether it's health insurance whether
it's i.t whether it's just
vendors for facilities we always look
outside the box that way
but we also look at outside the box in
terms of finding other opportunities for
revenue
currently the community college system
has over 15 million dollars worth
of grants that are managed under for 54
different projects and areas across the
seven
colleges so we're constantly trying to
find ways to
extend our reach and allow our employees
to service our students in the best
possible ways
we do in we've increased our fundraising
capabilities in the last three years
significantly
and the last bullet point on the box to
the left goes exactly to what chancellor
hughes was
just saying we are still and continue to
work with the synergies group and the
university system
to provide better leveraging power
economies of scale in terms of
purchasing
the three uh examples that we can give
our canvas kaltura
and zoom which will come later those are
contracts that are already signed right
now that have saved us money
but we continue to look at aligning
contracts
within the it operations of both
entities
to see when things are aligning in order
to again
leverage that economies of scale
the next slide shannon please
and in terms of our i.t sustainability
our focus is being able to expand our
reach and maximize
the impact of our personnel to improve
student outcomes and experiences
excuse me this is done by using a
centrally managed i.t infrastructure
across the entire system
which allows for greater efficiencies in
terms of things like
support purchasing automation and
managing the actual performance of the
infrastructure that we have
we pride ourselves on maintaining the
assets that we have
whether it's hardware or software
because we want it to be
uniform across the seven schools so we
when we look to buy things we look to
buy things
that all seven colleges use our student
information system
our learning management system our
advising system
are all platforms that whether you're in
nashua concord
berlin or river valley the students know
all of that programming because it's
across all seven colleges so we try to
utilize our ability to to go forward and
provide sustainability in that manner we
also look at finding a way to
automate things that have been very
manual and very time consuming in the
past
so the two examples that we have here
are dynamic forms and app works which
are two particular programs
degree works takes a manual process
and puts it into an electronic format so
can it it can be routed
efficiently and free up time from
someone to have to
fill up things in triplicate from the
old days app works is a software
component that takes
manual data entry that used to take
weeks
in past processes and allows it to get
it
get down in hours or a day so what we're
trying to do is be able to free up the
manpower
to do other things to support our
student focused mission
while allowing us to maintain our
ability to do that uh
and chancellor hewitt just mentioned the
stimulus packages what we've done is
we've really tried to strategically use
the fundings that we've gotten from
cares carissa and when the american
rescue act funds come in what that
has done will allows us to bolster our
academic technology so we can be able to
share
courses online to
reduce our footprint in the building so
we can have a greater reach to our
students
uh and again i mentioned canvas caltour
and zoom one slide too early but these
are some of the technologies that we use
in order to save some funds across the
board by working with the university
system
again the examples on the right are just
some of the things that we've
we've done at a micro level in terms of
changing out some of the it
infrastructure that allows for greater
bandwidth
greater efficiencies and things of that
nature
thank you scott so we've done all of
this to
maintain affordability and we share this
chart of our tuition
you can see from 2000 2001
until 2010 2011
we kept raising tuition
uh we came to our senses in 2011
and realized that we are in a
partnership with our students
and if we are going to support our
students
we need to have the opportunity to keep
tuition as affordable
as we can and with your help we've done
that
in fact we've only raised our tuition by
two percent
in ten years now this has taken a huge
amount of
discipline it's taken additional funding
from all of you
which we are very grateful for
but it's also taken discipline on our
side of the house
and looking at where we can find
additional dollars to support our
students
and it ranges from public partners to
private partners like the new hampshire
charitable foundation and i will call
out the medallion fund
and the work that has happened there to
support our students who have gone into
the technical trades
and when i first went to work at
manchester community college
i was truly surprised to find out how
much tools cost
uh the fact that if you want to go into
hvac you need about
a thousand dollars worth of tools you
want to go into automotive technology
it's about two thousand dollars worth of
tools
uh because if you're working in uh the
in the technical trades the expectation
is that you're going to bring your own
tools and so we've
had to work on things as basic as how
can we help students to get the tools
that they need you know the
pell grants will cover their tuition
but not for instance if they're in a
profession that requires
uniforms and so on so it's been an
all-in
and then all consideration for us
to help our students uh one of the
things and you'll notice the second
bullet in
orange because this is a project between
our two systems
has been this thing called oer open
educational resources
in the last two years we have saved our
students
close to a million dollars in textbooks
i think you've all heard the stories
about textbooks
well together we've worked on
identifying
high quality free resources and
a tip of the hat to robin derosa who
leads this effort she's at plymouth
state university and she's been
instrumental in helping us to grow there
the other piece though as i was
mentioning before is how do we keep the
students coming
because they have families to support
and in the pandemic
we've needed to create and maintain food
pantries
transportation assistance uh
you know closets with interview quality
uh clothing for students
and we've done all of this and we've
paid very careful attention to our fees
and in fact i
i appreciate that our presidents will
take one another on
when one particular college wants to
raise a fee to say
do you really need that money do you
really need
to ask our students to pay more and in
some cases the answer is i
i guess not let me work on this a little
bit better
uh and finally to pick up on what uh
scott was talking about we're trying to
build a culture of
philanthropy we did our first annual
fund
appeal uh this year there hasn't been
one
i don't know that there's ever been one
i remember again doing one at
manchester a number of years ago but but
we're asking
our very proud graduates who are
staffing all of the businesses
in our state to contribute to
that next generation of workers that are
coming out
so now we're going to look at additional
numbers and so if we can go to the
appendix please
and i will turn us back over to scott
and the point we want to make here we
know that you can read our slides and so
on
we want you to see that this is not a
brand new project
for us but over the last um 10 years we
have looked for ways
to reduce our expenditures
and the cost and so scott i don't know
if there are a few places here we just
want to point out
one or two statistics to uh the
committee
um sure we can we can start on
this uh slide where do you want to go
shannon
it's up to you scott you tell me the
benefits slide is is fine if you want to
stick with that and then maybe we'll go
to the um
the person i want after that so on the
slide here this has got the last uh
four fully closed year four full years
of
audited financial information in these
particular areas so
in terms of benefits you can see that
we've done
an exceedingly good job in to reduce
expenses as the chancellor said earlier
as the demands
change within our marketplace we are
entrepreneurial enough to change with
them
and then so you'll see in our overall
benefit costs have
steadily declined and the 17.65
decline is the four-year accumulated
total from
fy 17 through fy 20.
we've done this again as we alluded to
earlier is negotiating
good contracts with our health insurance
carriers and our dental carriers and
things of that nature so
you can see in the second group of uh
of the chart our overall health
insurance cost has gone down nearly you
know four and a half percent
over that time frame and as all you all
know
health insurance can be a very fickle
thing because it depends on
the health of the people within your
organization who rolls off who comes on
and all of these things so
the fact that we've managed to keep it
relatively even and go down even a
little bit is a substantial win
for the community college system the
next section down is our dental
insurance program nearly 25
down by doing the same thing again
conservatively managing the
negotiating the benefits within our
package to
ensure optimal roi on what we're
looking to provide for our faculty and
staff
the next section over is our
employee hra program that's gone down 25
over the last couple years and the one
thing i wanted to call out and i know
i've mentioned this at other hearings is
one of the things that we are trying to
do in your funding is so critical for us
is for some of the things that we cannot
we have no say in that are mandated by
the state which is this the retiree
health portion as you see here has gone
up actually over 69
over the last four fiscal years this is
a cost that we absorb
as we move forward but the offsetting
savings from these prior charts allows
us to do that but just
to show where we've again proactively
tried to reduce costs
and other costs we have to absorb
because they're mandated to us
scott i'm aware of um the time that
we're taking up
so i'm going to pull this back from you
and just
shannon ask for a quick show of the
personnel slide that
and again you can see that
we have looked actively at ways to
reduce
costs but yet maintain the quality
programming that we need
some of this is a reflection shannon if
you want to go on to the next slide as
well
of the fact that we have changed our
staffing based upon
what programs we're offering and and
what
it is again aligns with what the state
needs
so you can see the drop in our
expenditures
you can see the reductions in our
staffing and we'll go to the last
slide as shannon which is here on the
system office
you know as people think about this
notion of merger
one of the first things they think about
is well you know both systems have
central offices so let's just merge
those central offices
there must be a lot of people there who
are duplicating efforts
and we thought we would lay out for you
exactly who does what
in in our system office there are 40
full-time people
and two part-timers working in our
office you can see how those folks
lay out and since 2015
we have reduced the head count in our
system office by condensing positions
by using technology uh that supports
efforts rather than having
um you know people do the work in a non
in a manual way rather than an automated
way
to again be good stewards of the money
that
we raise through student tuition and
that you have
sent our way as the state allocation so
i thank you for listening to us we're
happy to answer any questions you might
have
i if it's okay um
i would like the university system to
provide their briefing and then
uh representative porter hold your write
your question down
and uh then we'll um we'll get back
to you so um
i'm not sure who's going to talk first
uh
joe it looks like your um microphone is
on
i i think i will but um kathy will uh
jump in with slides in a second and i'll
walk through the first half of the
slides and
let's do a walk through the second half
um you know other than representative
umberger and representative murray i've
never met any of you so
um madam chair if you don't mind i'll
just take a minute to
introduce myself uh that's okay
yeah absolutely so i've been
on the board for eight years the last
two years i've been chair of the
previous three i was
chair of finance when i joined the board
i was ceo of albany international
and served in that role for 12 years
recently retired and was responsible for
moving the company
from new york to new hampshire and
building that
large aerospace operation in rochester
before that job i was president of
bentley university for eight years
and before that i was a professor of
business strategy
and then a dean at the business school
at rpi i started my career at ge
and spent four years working for
president reagan's science advisor
and my beat back way back then at the
beginning of my career was
industry higher ed relationship so my
whole career has been bouncing back and
forth between
business and higher ed i i joined the
board
when when the governor asked if i'd be
interested
i jumped at the opportunity because this
was
early in the early last decade and we
were
really struggling to find the talent
to build this we needed to hire about
500 people
to build this high-tech operation in
rochester
and i i think those of you who
[Music]
have spent plenty of time in and around
manufacturing the state know the only
way we can manufacture in this state
is by focusing on high value added
differentiated products and processes we
can't compete on the basis of cost but
we can compete on the basis of
of uh differentiated products and
manufacturing but that requires talent
and across the board talent from
associates degrees on the factory floor
to industrial engineers with bachelor's
and master's degrees who run the plants
to
research scientists and engineers and
i'd say i spent the better part of my
life those first few years
trying to figure out how we were going
to find the talent we developed a
wonderful
at the time path breaking program with
great bay
a training program for us and our
partner
that was situated in rochester we also
made a significant gift to great bay but
we're also working
considerably with unh as well i have to
tell you that for all of those efforts
we we were forced to recruit an awful
lot of people from out of state it was
really frustrating and
really expensive and
but not because of a lack of effort on
the part of the community colleges of
the university system they were great
partners
at nothing but admiration everything
susan has described in our colleagues
have described that
boy i just from an employer point of
view to just
admire it without reservation um
we actually backed away from our plan
to bring over our full headquarters we
had about
40 to 50 really good jobs in accounting
and finance we were a public company
global company
and we had to leave them back in albany
because we simply couldn't find
enough talent to staff those positions
so
it was with at that level of frustration
it was about that peak frustration that
the governor asked if i'd
be interested in joining the board and i
jumped at it because i thought this
would be a shot at
helping to work the problem so that's
that's my background and if
if you hear a little passion or
frustration in what you're about to hear
as we
sort of look out toward the future of
higher ed it's got it is
not in any way based on criticism of the
experience
that i had with our higher ed partners
but
really a sense of deep concern
about where higher ed in general and in
the state public higher ed is heading
and what the implications of that
potential
wave after wave of challenge is going to
is going to mean
for the employers of the state and
therefore for the future economy of the
state
particularly the employers who are
concerned about bringing in the kind of
jobs that we really want in this state
so with that as a backdrop sorry to if
i've gone long-winded uh kathy could you
put up the
the second slide
could you go to the next one please
so um you know the starting point for
us and and i'm speaking
um i'm really speaking on behalf of our
board here although everything i'm about
to say i feel
passionate about personally the the we
we have spent the last few years as a
board
trying to come to grips with the
implications
of a dramatic downturn in
the demographics that is in the pool of
students
um that that we'll be serving in higher
education and
just just to put this in context higher
education
has been growing steadily with a couple
of bumps along the way but it's
it's been a growth industry since world
war ii in the gi bill
this is the first time that we've seen a
demographic downturn and if you can look
at the left slide
um that purple line there
uh it starts in 2018 uh declines a
little bit through mid-decade and then
falls off a cliff
um that's the pool of that's the en
of uh potential students available to
four-year uh institutions like the usnh
institutions
in the northeast the purple line um this
is a regional slide
um now uh
there are a couple of things going on
here but one is simply
they're just fewer people being born
and uh so we can project with complete
accuracy or the
demographers can how many 18 year olds
they're going to be in 18 years
the the second point here is you'll see
that the the dominant um
uh forecasters for higher education this
is
nathan grah project
the same essentially the same curve in
the northeast for two-year
or two-year colleges
it hits first of course with that that
pool of
uh roughly 20 percent of the two-year
college students who are
uh 16 to 20 year olds but of course
those demographics
are going to wash through the whole
population in the two-year school so
this is like gravity this is coming
there's no there's no avoiding this the
this is going to be a decline in market
unlike
anything that has hit higher ed it's
going to feel more like the textile
industry or the paper industry
by the time we get to a little after
mid-decade there's no avoiding this now
it it is exacerbated by
a problem that people in higher ed don't
like to talk to very much
talk about very much um the elite
schools are not going to have any
problem here
even though the pool of students is
shrinking they're going to be fine
because all they're going to do
to fill their class is they're going to
go cherry-pick
the best students out of the tier of
schools
who they used to reject kids from so
they'll they'll cherry-pick the top
students from tufts and from
harvard and mit will cherry-pick the top
students from tufts and
bc who will then turn around and charit
to fill their class
cherry pick the top students from bu and
umass amherst and umass lowell
who will then to fill their class turn
around and cherry pick
from the best students of unh and umaine
who will in turn animalize
their brethren at plymouth and keene who
in turn
will turn to that pool of transfer
students in the two-year schools
and cherry-pick from them as well and so
the farther down the food chain you are
in higher ed nobody talks about this the
more vulnerable you are to these
trends and and we're already seeing it
you know we look at the top
10 competitors quote unquote
uh to unh that is who when we look at
who
we've applaud who's applied to unh and
who's been admitted
among the top 10 competitors are
plymouth and keen
when we look at keen among the top 10
competitors are unh
plymouth and nhti when we look at
plymouth state
among the top 10 competitors are unh and
keene state but also
nhti in great bay so as the pool shrinks
there's a massive game
of musical chairs going on and the more
vulnerable you are
in the rankings if you will the more
committed you are
or dedicated you are to serving poorer
populations the more vulnerable you are
to these demographic
yes and we're getting hit hard with it
and and all the data says
two-year schools two-year colleges and
systems around the northeast are as well
kathy if you go to the next slide now
that's half the problem
and and remember we're only at the front
end of this
this is going to get much worse there's
no question that it's going to get much
worse it's like gravity the second
phenomenon which is hidden from view
on those first demographic slides is the
growing financial need
of the students we serve in both our
systems
i'll just talk about usnh and and again
there's
two dynamics going on the first is that
shrinking population
is just poor and you can see it
in the in in the composition of
of those demographics so in in the year
um 29 of college age
or higher education age students were
people of color uh by 2018 the beginning
of that slide it's 45
and and people of color in general that
beta shows overwhelmingly are poorer
than uh
than than their white counterparts in in
20 in the year 2000 20
of that population was immigrants
or the children of immigrants today it's
in
by 2018 it's 28 and that number will
continue to grow too
so shrinking number of students
growing amount of financial need and
then you have to layer on top of that
another reality that people in higher ed
don't like to talk about
there's there's an all-out price war
going on right now
uh because the pool of students is
shrinking
and the price war is taking the form not
of drops in tuition but of increases in
financial aid
and so the way the way schools that are
struggling to fill their
class with a smaller pool respond
is by trying to quote-unquote steal
other schools students by offering
better packages
and you get an arms race here of
escalating increase in financial aid
so if you look at usnh
and you look at the amount of financial
aid that we've been providing
just over the last few years you can see
the steady increase
big numbers so there's
there's a serious
revenue crisis that higher education
of all stripes is heading into and it's
taking the form
of a sharp decline in net revenue
that is the result of a combination of a
shrinking pool of students
and the growing growing financial need
of those students
and the accompanying price for
it will we are at the beginning of this
if you go
if you think back to that demographic
slide just go back for one second kathy
uh just look at that waterfall starting
in mid-decade
okay so uh if you go so now what's the
consequence of this the consequence of
this
is revenue begins to fall
and as revenue begins to fall
you try to take cost out as rapidly as
you can but
margins begin to erode so for usnh
from from fiscal year 17 so essentially
the beginning of that demographic chart
you can see that our revenue has dropped
because of these two factors
has dropped by about eight percent or 27
million dollars
our state funding the line in red so
that's that's the blue that's
tuition based net revenue so we're
leaving aside contracts and grants
tuition-based net revenue declined from
329.5 million
to 302 million over this period
state support was was flat happily
thank you it started to increase a bit
uh
in the past biennium but but you can see
that given the magnitude
of the decline 27 million eight percent
the much appreciated increase in finance
in uh state support doesn't come close
to
covering the effect um and we understand
there are limits to what you can do i'm
not not here pitching for more funds i'm
just trying to show you the magnitude of
the squeeze
and so the result is if you look at
those gray bars on the left side those
are our operating margin
and you can see that the operating
margin has basically shrunk from one and
a half percent which
isn't particularly good uh in in fiscal
year 17 to this year
excluding the one-time effects of covet
it's actually operating a lot worse if
you include cloven
but excluding the one-time effects of
covert we're we're going to lose about
two percent
now you know if you if you look over
uh the comparable data over on the
on the ccsnh side you can see net
tuition and revenue
is getting hammered by the same forces
that are hitting us
so net tuition is declined from
from 47.9 million to 39 million exactly
what all of the data in higher ed is
telling us
it's going to hit is hitting uh
two-year institutions in the northeast
very hard happily
fortunately and i'll say this jen i
i would say our board is cheering this
trend this
the state has stepped up and has been
able to
offset those declines and um
we it and and
thank you for that from an employee
former employer's point of view that's
that's wonderful action
now the bottom line um
a declining
net revenue picture uh
that's going to be too big in all
likelihood for the state to offset over
time
um declining margins
and we're at the front end of this now
before
uh kathy starts telling you how we're
trying to get
to at least catch up to these trends uh
just a couple more points
if you go to the next slide we we as a
state
public higher education in this state is
you
is in a uniquely
weak position to take this crisis on so
we're entering into
a step change in the nature
of higher education starting from a weak
position
so as you i'm sure you will know we
export in four-year schools four-year
enrollment we export nearly 60 percent
of high school graduates
going on to four-year enrollment and you
know again if you think about this from
an employer point of view once they go
it's hard to get them back
it's like recruiting somebody from
outside the state
and if you combine both two-year and
four-year we lose more than fifty
percent
or we lose we lose close to fifty
so that's number one number two if you
go to the next slide
um we we have
very high tuition very high net
after financial aid net cost of
attendance so if you
this is for four-year schools you want
to look at the blue
line here so the blue line represents
in-state tuition the orange on top of
that represents
out-of-state tuition so the total bar is
total tuition
but you can see that if you just focus
on the blue
new hampshire is all the way over on the
right just
just before vermont we have the second
highest
net tuition in the country for a public
university
and you know that compares to an average
in the country of about 10 million in
10 000 in light blue
now same thing same thing with our
brethren in the two-year for
i mean they've done as susan described a
fantastic
job holding the line um but
likewise we're we're we're approaching
the crisis
as the second most expensive uh system
in in the country to attend now what
this says
is neither the four years nor the two
years
can afford to raise tuition
to address this revenue crisis you just
can't
raise tuition if you tried
the market won't let you get away with
it you're going to wind up paying you're
going to wind up off setting it with
increased financial aid anyway but
but part of our crisis or part of our
challenge as
as a state is not only do we have to
find
ways of reducing costs to offset
that 25-ish percent collapse
in revenue net revenue we should be
looking for ways to reduce costs to
lower tuition
we've got to get to a lower tuition
we've got to get to
more affordable public higher education
across the board
and so that's why our you know our
proposal when we submitted it
um our budget proposal said well we'll
hold tuition flat again as we have for
quite a few years now but if you give us
an increase
we will use that to lower tuition and so
another
one of the hidden challenges here is
um it would be a lot easier to deal with
this revenue crisis if we were on the
left-hand side of the slide
one last point here which speaks to
the challenge this state is going to
face
in public higher education in the years
to come
we also approach this if you go to the
next slide kathy
you know not only are we the highest
exporter of high school students not
only do we have among the highest
tuition highest net cost of attendance
we're also structured in one of the
least efficient
manners in the country so if you just
look at the population
of a state
against the number of institutions
in higher education we're about 40th
in the country that is uh the more
population you serve per institution the
more efficient you are
the less population you serve per
institution
the less efficient you are because every
institution you have means
fixed costs that are that are
unavoidable so
if you look at the right hand column the
population
of you look at state by state and look
at the population of people who are
under 25
and look at the number of institutions
that each state has
to serve that population we're we're the
41st
least efficient that is we have 41st
rank 41st in terms of number of
institutions per population served and
most of the
states below us tend to be
geographically dispersed
large geographies with dispersed
populations so
if you go to the next slide kathy so
essentially where our board is coming
from
is we are deeply concerned
um about a fundamental
structural permanent accelerating
change hitting public higher education
it's why the board
our board voted unanimously
to to basically instruct me
to get in touch with the leadership of
ccsnh a year ago
to see if we could start having joint
conversations
uh it's what eventually led to um
that a working group to look for
synergies that
susan and her colleagues mentioned and
it's it's why we
uh formally voted in the autumn to
invite
uh the community college board to uh
consider
a joint group to explore possible
relationships and it's why we responded
so positively
when the governor um made his proposal
because
in our minds this is going to be this is
this
this is unprecedented in higher ed it's
going to take
very strong governance very strong
leadership
constant strategic planning
and adjusting and a lot of honesty
amongst ourselves and amongst um
the legislators and and um and governor
so that's our starting point now we also
understand
and and long before the governor made
his proposal we knew was our duty as a
board to get our
system uh as well as well positioned
for this tsunami as we could and so
kathy will just walk you through the
plan that we've put in place
to reduce our total expenses by
essentially 10
um which we believe with a little luck
will allow us to catch up to the trends
by 2023 and buy us some time to prepare
for the waterfall
in 2526. so kathy over to you
thanks thanks joe good morning good
morning everyone for the record my name
is catherine provencher and i
serve as chief administrative officer of
the university system good to be with
you
folks all again um so so with that
um terrific
summary of what we are headed into
and have been living for some time
our board's been focused on this for
probably four plus
years and we've been doing multi-year
financial planning
um during that whole during that whole
period
but covet really brought an urgency that
we we obviously could not avoid and we
undertook a very
significant effort last spring to do
financial modeling
and project revenues out to
2023 to make sure that post pandemic
we were on a trajectory for fiscal
sustainability and in that financial
modeling
we made assumptions relative to future
enrollment based on
demographics as joe mentioned we made
assumptions about
the financial aid needs of our students
residency mix state support
fundraising all of those things we we
modeled
out and the result of that was we needed
to take out 10
of our costs by 2023 to be back in the
in
in the black if you will and
and um all of the campuses had
undertaken
work to identify various opportunities
that that we could grab onto in order to
put a roadmap together on how we are
going to achieve that
that reduction in our in our cost
structure
just one just one uh additional piece of
context we
we knew this covert year was going to be
a disaster
and we we made a collective decision
that we we would spend whatever it would
take
to keep our students and faculty and
staff
safe even if it meant running huge
losses
as long as we could come
we could do what we needed to do to come
out of
the covert year in a financially stable
place
right so what that what that modeling
showed us is that our
our revenue excluding grants and
contracts and when i say grants
our grants from uh noaa
and nsf you know unh has significant
grant dollars so we excluded that
because that's a dollar and a dollar out
but our revenue is projected to drop
nine percent
excuse me from fiscal 20 to fiscal 23
which is how we arrived at the 70
million dollars that we need to take out
of our cost structure
to have a very slim
1 margin by fiscal 23
and so how are we going to do that
we put a plan together in categories if
you will
so the first category when we adopted
the budget for this
fiscal year fiscal 21 it was
roll all your spending back to fiscal 19
actual
and that would take 10 and and remember
when we're doing this we're at the
toward the end of fiscal 20 getting
ready to adopt our
fiscal 21 budget and that roll back
must be sustained into future years
so that took about 10 million dollars
out of the cost structure
we then put a category together
of shared opportunities across the
university system so those would be
cross cutters across all of our campuses
a significant one was employee benefits
restructuring
you know this is an area where when
revenue is shrinking
and that is a fixed cost it puts
real pressure on on the income statement
on the on the bottom line
so we've been focused on employee
benefits restructuring
we have done some of that work already
we're negotiating other parts of it
another again these are when you have
fixed cost
like the unfunded pension liability that
that scott mentioned earlier
that it just puts pressure on
the community college system when you
can't break through that
that unfunded pension liability the next
three items procurement
i.t and financial services again we have
[Music]
cost reduction estimates there we're
actually exceeding on it
and financial services right now but
those three i sit on that
ccsnh and usnh synergies working group
and we've already achieved as mentioned
during
the community college's presentation
some benefits in procurement and i.t
so i recognize that there are all
other opportunities there in the area of
procurement
i.t and i i'm sure financial services as
well
and um category three are campus
specific reductions that work is ongoing
at each of the campuses academic
restructuring
program evaluation to make sure we're
aligning
enrollment with capacity
um and and that works being done
but then as revenue can as joe mentioned
we're at the beginning
of the challenges that we see coming
down the road
the next wave will be and we have some
pilot projects going on but
course sharing across our campuses
and there's opportunity potentially with
ccsnh as well
the um i scott also mentioned
that the um federal stimulus money
provided opportunity for the community
colleges to invest in
academic technology the same is true at
the university system
where where course sharing is um
is starting to be evaluated and uh we're
working on that for the again for
the next wave that we know is going to
have significant revenue pressure
on us so how are we executing on this
plan
uh a primary tool was an early
retirement program that was offered
last fall 50 of those people that were
eligible took advantage of that plan and
there are 480 employees
leaving the university system during
this fiscal year
so so that was a significant tool to get
us to the 70 million dollars in cost
reductions that we need by
fiscal 23. i talked about the benefit
changes
i t consolidation is complete we've
exceeded those savings targets
we're in the middle of the financial and
administrative restructure and i
i mentioned the campus specific
initiatives
those are my only comments i i really
want to make sure that we
leave time for for questions
and i will stop sharing so
folks can see one another
the last point i i it to just give you a
sense
of the how our board views this
these are necessary at times painful
restructuring
10 of our people um
it just catches us up to those trends
doesn't get us ahead of them
it uh we hope it'll buy us a few years
to then figure out the next wave of
of steps um and
uh this this is going to be a permanent
part of how we
do business over the next 10 years
thank you yeah thank you all for your
uh presentations it's
it's good to see that you're not sitting
there just uh
wringing your hands on either of the
place
either either side that um
you're actually making some progress
which i think is
um is extremely important
especially when we look at the
demographics of our state and the
um and the fact that so many of our
students
choose to go out of state to
um to college um you know whether it's
the two-year the four-year
but and i'm not exactly sure how we can
eliminate that but you know that's a
that's a choice
that the children and the parents make
and i think uh as has been
mentioned one of the one of the reasons
for that
is because our tuition and fees are
quite high and as a result
they can go to another university
out of state and get better um aid
packages
and so all of that you know plays a role
in uh in what we can do so
representative porter you had a question
a while ago i'm sorry but
i just thought it was good that we you
know got both briefings
and then uh asked the questions and
we've got we have plenty of time so
don't
don't hold that chair and actually it's
good because
i got more information from my questions
and it's
it's uh kind of grown into two so can i
ask the two questions
absolutely go ahead you can even ask you
can ask three
oh okay thanks so the first question
that i had had to do with
um the numbers of adjunct faculty that
are being used at the community colleges
and then
listening to um you and the university
system
i guess it transfers over to that so
that was my first question
is there going to be an increase in the
use of that those faculty members
and the second question is if
we're reducing staff this much and and
reducing everything this much
is it also reducing the um programs and
offerings that we have to give to
students
um you know what i heard in the unh i
mean in the community college
was that you're expanding some of those
offerings but yet
if we're going to be reducing the number
of people working
is is how is that going to work and
those are my
two questions
oh absolutely thank you
thank you representative porter for the
question um
part of the answer is efficiency where
in some cases before we would have run
a tiny class we've
we have collapsed sections so that the
enrollment is larger
we're still staying in a a place where
our average cost enrollment
is just into double digits 10 11
12 but we've had to make
more thoughtful decisions about
how it is we employ part-time faculty
and in some cases when we are talking
about
new programming rather than hiring a
full-time
faculty member to begin with we will
begin with part-time faculty because we
don't know if the program's going to be
viable
and we don't know uh what all of the
components need to be so we use adjunct
faculty
in a variety of ways you know if you if
you talk about
some of the classic transfer courses
like uh english composition for example
there are a number of full-time faculty
members but there's usually a pretty
good size contingent
of part-time faculty in those places
the other thing that we do with adjunct
faculty is bring in practitioners
because that really is what finishes off
the education that we can offer
our students so you know um i think
about
um the hvac program well joel pickering
who uh is the principal at denron
plumbing
teaches within the hvac program the
line worker program employs either
recently retired or close to retirement
line worker utility workers so that our
students are actually learning from
people in the field
so there's been a variety of things that
we've done with adjuncts faculty
so i think uh our answer
is pretty similar to to susan's
uh you know the the as
i think as as you were suggesting
representative porter the the real
challenge here is how do you preserve
your ability to deliver the mission of
affordable access to good quality
education while you're cutting and
the the short answer uh in addition to
what
susan was describing is if you know
higher ed has been
in growth mode for 75 years
and one of the consequences is the
incremental
addition of small program on top of
small program for small numbers of
students and then you hire some faculty
to
support those programs so if you can
find a way
of rebalancing and uh
and cutting back on small enrolled
programs
and courses with small numbers of
students and redirect
the reduced resources to the programs
where there are
there's greater demand for student and
more in larger classes than
then you can pull this off without
diminishing quality the
the problem with being able to make that
kind of a shift
is is in higher edge you've got tenured
faculty
and so if you if you were hired 30 years
ago to teach in one field which was
of demand then and no longer is you're
still
you're you're still pursuing your job um
even though they're not that many
students so the reason that we felt it
was so critical to
go to a voluntary retirement program
was to give faculty who
might otherwise not be able to afford to
retire the opportunity to do so and
hope that that would open up enough
positions that we could then do this
kind of
research allocation across programs
questions oh certainly go ahead
follow up okay so years and years ago my
late husband
had degreed to teach in colleges and
checked out
adject faculty positions and at that
time they were paid by credit
so they earned so much per credit that
they taught
is that still the structure or are they
on some kind of salary now
representative porter it's both depends
it depends on the course it depends on
the program
some adjuncts receive per credit but
there are other adjunct faculty that
that are on salary thank you and i think
the key
on the adjunct was the point that's that
susan made that if you have a
a core of faculty you can supplement
them with people with specialized
clinical real world expertise and
it really helps to fill out your
programs president did you
yeah did you have a comment um
the thank you representative um
we don't i don't believe we have any
part-time faculty on
a salary i believe everyone is is paid
by uh
credit okay
uh representative turcotte i believe
your hand was next
thank you madam chair i'm not sure if
this is for uh
joe or catherine uh but on the slide
presentations on
page seven and eight um that talks about
the uh relative tuition uh by
each state could you give me the top
say two or three components or reasons
why that is you know when i first
looked at it my gut would say all right
the high tax states would be at one end
in the low tax states at the other but
it's not the case so whoever wants to
handle that
also before i go if joe and susan could
you send me your emails i know
catherine's is at the end
i have to leave this in about 12 minutes
so
i i think i'll have some more questions
for you thank you
representative the the the primary
driver for that high
end state tuition is in fact
the relatively low state support
per student or per capita in new
hampshire
relative to other states around the
country i'd have to go back and look at
all of the states i mean some of the
states in the west it has to do with
um they may not have an income tax but
they have high
natural resources i'm thinking wyoming
and alaska et cetera
so um that's the that's the primary
driver i will also say that
new england in relation to many other
parts of the country is a higher has a
higher cost of living
so so that's relative as well to you
know across the 50 states
but the main the main driver is the
first one that
that kathy mentioned it's the data is
there if you look at
state support per per capita we're we're
pretty much the lowest in the country or
near the lowest in the country
but look uh nobody wants a state income
tax
so it that's our reality to to
you know um what it means is it's not
going to change
so we've got to be more efficient in
other states that's the only that's the
only way you get around it unless
you want to live with higher tuition and
i don't think we can afford to live with
higher tuition much longer
put follow-up madam chair yes
uh you mentioned uh state contributions
per capita do you would you have that
data available
just for me personally i've never been
involved with this so i'd be great thank
you
okay um representative lynn
i think you were next
thank you this is really directed to to
both uh
the university system and the community
college system i'm wondering um
if you have if each of you have
uh some kind of data that you that in
written form that you could provide to
us
that would show for example let's say
over the last five or six years
total number of students total
faculty members uh and i'm particularly
concerned about full-time but
it could include part-time too if that's
the way you do it but
so total students total faculty members
and then
the thing that's most important to me
total non-faculty employees
because one of the things that that you
know i've heard has been a real issue
not
not and i'm not trying to single out new
hampshire but just
generally around the country is that
while there's been this pressure
from uh sort of a reduction in students
there seems to have been uh uh
a discordant if you will uh increase in
the in the
in the uh ranks of administrators of one
kind or another and uh
i just would be interested in in seeing
if you have that
those kind of numbers and if we could
get them
certainly we we track that data
thank you the community college i
believe also tracks that
yes yes some of it is available through
ipads
um representative lynn it'll be a bit of
a challenge for us to capture
our non-credit short-term training uh
but we will give you that information as
well
thank you very much i appreciate that
welcome i'll just
follow up a representative lynn that the
early retirement program
will also that won't that data won't
you know it hasn't happened yet but
that's also going to have a sig
both faculty and staff there were a lot
of people that took
took that advantage of the program so so
the data
that i provide will not yet reflect that
10 reduction in our workforce maybe we
can
maybe we can add that i think we did
some estimates of that right
and we yes and we do have it by faculty
staff yeah
that that would be great thank you very
much that would be very helpful
representative heath well thank you
ma'am chair first of all i just want to
say
both your presentations were excellent
um
just um it always really upsets me when
i think about our university
systems and the community college system
struggling the way they are because they
are such a huge benefit to our state
so my my big question is why agree to
the merger
before a plan is established without a
road map
um just wouldn't it be better to take
the year to create the plan
before we legislate a merger and and
secondly
you know i look at the funding that that
we
actually for the university system and
the community college
we're giving you more money we're giving
you less money to do more
um we we didn't maintain the level of
funding
from the last biennium and i just i'm
concerned
um because we are putting you in a
position
to do double duty work um
to come up with some kind of a road map
and plan
to significantly change the way
not only the university system works but
the community
of the community college system as well
and it just
i feel like the city i was glad to hear
about the synergy group and all the work
that's already been done
but my concern is is this too fast
too soon or instead of a merger
legislated in hb2 should we take
a year to really give the synergy group
a chance to get going and have a road
map of where we're going
and i whoever wants to answer that
question i'm happy to listen
[Music]
go ahead susan i'm sure we have
different views on this so
we do we do have different we do have
different views on it i mean
we're interested in in what can happen
by being combined but we
share many of the concerns that you're
raising right now representative heath
um our when we look
when we review the literature that's
available on the mergers in the
20 other states it's
adversely affected the community
colleges it is
it is the mission of the community
colleges
that gets lost and everybody starts in a
place
with excellent intentions
but where things go within a three-year
period
in terms of the ability of community
colleges
to meet the mission that they have
that's where the problem is and and uh
and joe and i have
have spoken about this and i don't
disagree
with the statistics i i probably do
with how we see um the demographics
within the state and our opportunities
certainly i agree that our opportunities
for students have been
diminished but i i do see other
opportunities based in you know that was
why we put up the demographic
slide that we did so i think
based upon the conversations that we've
been hearing
i know that what our state is looking
for is a strong commitment
from ccsnh and usnh to look at this and
to make
good and realistic decisions and so we
absolutely are committed to that
but i will also say you know in in
in the covid times the state spent a
million dollars on a study
for bea in terms of economic development
it also spent 1.4 million
on looking at reorganizations for dhhs
however you look at higher ed we are the
future of the state
spend some money on us figure this out
we will continue the synergies work
what you know we can uh
you know i look forward to you putting
accountability in place so that you are
reassured that we are doubling down on
this work
but but we appear in this legislation to
be
starting at the end uh and and so let's
let's do some of the groundwork that
really needs to be done
i don't think my position will surprise
any of you i just
add to the the question for both of you
because i think it's so critically
important the college experience
for both systems is very different
and i believe in the future for the
community college system
we're going to see a workforce of a
totally different
age than the one being served by the
university system
and i just want to make sure that that
the systems
needs and the the needs of our
individual
students across the state be they young
or old
are met so um if you mr marone if you
would continue please
okay um so so first on the question of
should we study first and then merge
where where i come out and where our
board comes out
is um
this it's one thing to study in theory
have outside people come in to help you
uh with a group that doesn't have a
particular stake in implementing the
outcome
it's another thing to make the
commitment give
the responsibility for the planning to
the people who are going to be
who are going to be charged with
implementing it
and then give them the resources and the
cushion
to do the planning right so
in my experience across many sectors
and and many restructurings
it works much better to say yes we're
going to do this
create the new board give the new board
the charge
to lay out the map in a way that learns
all the lessons from other places
and crucially i think this is this
speaks precisely to your
i think very legitimate concern give
that board
the resources and the cushion
to do the planning right give them the
resources to
hire outside expertise and if you can
afford it don't cut their budgets right
away
give them a little time to develop the
road map but the people who should be
the
developing the road map are the people
who are going to own this it usually
doesn't work
otherwise i'll just give you an example
we have a
we have a zoom call next week with the
chancellor
of the pennsylvania state college system
and they're they're going through
a significant restructuring but
it's a restructuring that's been
undertaken
by the governing body and with all of
the participants who are going to be
involved
involved not by a
previous group that's looking forward
and anticipating what's going to take
place
you get real you get reality involved if
the people who have to implement the
plan are the ones who are responsible
for designing it so i i think the
governor's got it right
um on the question of the diversity
of of mission uh
i you know i i violently agree
and but but just give you two
slightly alternative perspectives um
to an employer there is one spectrum
of needs you you don't just need the
talents from the two-year system or the
talents from the four-year system
you need a broad array of talents and
you'd like to have a public higher ed
system that is
functioning in a way that is
getting us to the highest possible
quality at the lowest possible cost with
with uh with the employer's needs in
mind
and the second is within each of our two
systems now there's within each
there's a wide diversity of mission so
if you look at granite state it's a
totally different mission from unh which
is totally different from
plymouth which is totally different from
keane and i
i'm sure it's the same story within
the seven institutions of our our
brethren in ccsnh
and we've all learned i mean that's what
it means to be a system you've got to on
the one hand
respect the diversity of the various
missions
and identities but because you're a
mission you have a chance to actually
um provide support
for the ones that are being that are
being challenged
um uh in a way that you couldn't if it
was a stand-alone institution
you know plymouth and keane if we just
talk about our own system
would have a very hard time surviving as
stand-alone institutions
but as part of a system they're going to
make it
uh representative oh i'm sorry but yes
yes
i don't want to turn this into
any kind of uh competition between us
but i have to
and i loved your expression violently
agree i have to disagree
the seven community colleges well not
violently this time but i'm sure
there'll be one
excitedly how's that new adverb
that the the seven community colleges
may differ by local flavor but we have
the identical
mission and and i absolutely respect
that the
usnh colleges and universities have
different missions
they should our state needs them but but
what is needed from the community
college
is a universal mission across our our
state
so thank you uh representative petry you
have
a question yeah thank you uh madam chair
uh
the uh of the 20 uh merges that you've
seen around the country have you seen
any successes
in the mergers uh you know that you are
significant and how would you protect
the community college system
thank you for for that question
representative there are elements of
success in
quite a number of the mergers and those
are things that we could
look at the the piece
that i'm most concerned about because it
disappears early as the voice of the
community colleges
and um you know as you're hearing
we have different missions they may
ultimately all roll up
to the same place they are ultimately
about most folks in our state are
are going for an education so that they
end up with a satisfying and fulfilling
uh career and job so we do all get there
but
but we get there in different ways and
um
it just when an entity is created that
puts
all of these differing missions these
differing institutions together
it's it's the voice of the community
college that
uh suffers um you know our
where we serve such a a diverse
population
in terms of age and ability and interest
that um it's
the people's ability to focus on exactly
what it is that we need for
particular groups of students just
makes it easy to kind of slough off
particular groups in our previous call i
talked about the university of alaska
and what has happened to
the community colleges there and the
enrollment now granted
the enrollment in community colleges is
down nationally
for a whole bunch of reasons but
when that merger started in 1987
there was an intention to have a
difference in tuition
and that's where they they began where
the community college students were
paying a lower level
a lower rate for tuition than the
university students
but as time went on and the budget got
tighter the university was no longer
able to
or the unit of the system was no longer
support a lower tuition for the
community college students
and what happened as a result of that
community people who would attend
community college for home affordability
is a critical issue disappeared
and then and then ultimately that has a
poor effect on the state because
we need people to be well educated in
whatever path they take whether it's a
technical trade
or it's a professional area so
you know one of the things that i've
said repeatedly
is that as as i'm going forward with
this idea
what is it that is going to be done to
protect the voice of the community
college and i go back to
what i said a few minutes ago i believe
if you tell us from the beginning that
you're going to
that initially our voice will be heard
but as we go forward
not so much
uh representative petrie i think the
the view that susan is expressing
is supported by reality
it's just undeniable
that that is a risk here so the question
is
and yet none of us would argue that that
mission
is less important than any other higher
ed mission
and certainly you you're not going to
find an employer in the state
who would make that case they'll argue
as i've been trying to argue
that the state needs the full spectrum
of
of educational programs um in the most
affordable
manner possible and the most accessible
now
um the what i found really interesting
about the governor's
one of the many things i found really
interesting about the governor's
proposal
is that he skewed the board
structure over represent
the community colleges so it's five
board members selected by the usnh
institutions
five five board members selected by the
ccsnh institutions and
five board members at large selected by
the governor
if you did this you know the way most
organizations would
would put together a board it would
reflect
relative revenue and so you get
something like
um eight board members
from the usnh institutions and two from
uh the ccsnh institutions but this
by having five and five plus
five at large and one would hope the
five at large are people who
employers from the state and educators
from the state who have a deep
commitment to the public education
mission
and i think you could argue the people
that governors have been picking
for our various boards do have that
commitment
the the answer to the question how do
you how do you assure
the and protect over the long haul the
mission of the community college systems
is
the board and
and it is up to the way that is written
it is up to
the member institutions to recommend
their slate of nominees so
as long as the member institutions
among the two-year schools are selecting
strong advocates strong and effective
advocates
they'll have a powerful voice on the
board that's number one number two
the first action the board has to take
is to hire a chancellor
and um that i assume that board
is going to put together a committee
comprising
members of the universities of a
selection from the five
board members nominated by the
university system and an equal selection
of the five members
nominated by the community college
system so
that chancellor needs to be somebody
who is deeply committed to to the full
spectrum of missions
and again how do you ensure that that's
on that's that's in the hands of the
board
thank you both uh
representative murray you have a
question
thank you madam chair um i think two
questions because i think they're
related
um i've certainly talked to a number of
you about this i've been spending a lot
of time thinking of it
um i wanted to go back a little bit to
representative heath's um
remarks um about a timeline for this
it seems to me in my experience with
academia which is
moderately substantial uh there's
um the academic side and then there's
the business side
it seems that in the talking about this
merger
there would be a different approach from
the business side than there would be
from the academic side
and i'd like you to speak to that to
those issues how you see us moving
forward with the merger
on those two different tracks and then
there's a third element i was almost
going to refer to it as a third rail and
i think that would be a mistake because
i see the third element is the state
and there may be there should be some
interaction with this with the state in
doing some of this
i'm thinking in regards to
what the state could do to help move
this along and in particular
um for instance the pension liability if
the state could help out with pension
liability that you have to take off some
of the pressure from both the community
college and the university system
but that needs to be um a dynamic
active kind of a thing as opposed to
every two year there's a budget and
maybe
on the off year you can submit a bill if
you know if you're so inclined
so can you address the differences that
you would have to approach from the
academic which is
in my mind at least a four-year cycle
and we've talked i've talked to all of
you about this a little bit before
um what's involved with the business
cycle of it
and how you would see the state
interacting to try to help financially
dealing with some of the issues that the
merger is going to bring up i hope that
makes some sense
either one can go ahead go first second
doesn't matter
goes first this time okay okay
um i
i i they're they're well you've got
multiple questions in there and they're
all great
so um uh
i'm i'm hesitating because i can't
speak for the future board who know we
don't know what the future board is
going to look like that's in the hands
of
the governor and the two and the two
sets of institutions but
i would say um that what we learn
over and over and over is if you're
doing
this kind of a merger in crisis where
you're having to cut
just to balance the budget you're going
to make mistakes
and you you're going to compromise the
quality
of of your programs and and that's and
that's where
missions can get jeopardized so so we
all know this is going to be
a very difficult 10 to 15 years
if the more cushion that you can provide
the new board and the combined system
and and cushion takes multiple
forms one is just
no budget cuts a second
is support to enable the new board to
hire outside um
then then then you have the time to plan
correctly the easy things to do
like uh taking advantage of the overlaps
between the two system offices and
everything we were talking about the
synergies around i.t and
and um financial aid and benefits and
financial account finance accounting
you can do those you can do those back
room operations that don't affect your
student but you
you're buying time to carefully
plan the kinds of academic
um programs and changes that you're
eventually going to make you know if if
you have
time then then you can give
i'll just take an example a cluster of
two-year and four-year
institutions serving the manchester area
you can give them time to sort through
where there are obvious overlaps and
synergies and how you could
reduce those while better serving the
students
but if you're if you're in if you're
literally cutting budget in year two
you're not going to have the time to do
that intelligently and involve the
stakeholders and
map it out so i think that's the
the big thing that the state could do
for us
uh for the two systems to get this right
would be give us a question
and i'll take the notion of cushion that
joe is speaking about
and talk about the fact that not only
uh you know our faculty our staff
are really thrown by this conversation
uh we're in a pandemic and we're also
talking about
merging uh two entities potentially
sloughing off
um you know colleges and so on and
um
if there's a way to have a cushion
so that people can focus on doing the
work that
joe has just described without worrying
i mean i i
i've had literally dozens of calls
saying
am i going to lose my medical insurance
on july 1.
we there are people in these systems if
i don't even speak about students right
now and i just speak about our employees
there are lots of very nervous people so
as um the state is asking us
to do the work of creating a more
efficient more effective
public higher ed entity what can you do
to support the people who are doing the
work
on a day-to-day basis
[Music]
you're asking people to have very hard
conversations they're worthy
conversations
but they're hard conversations
[Music]
there are any number of things that
representative murray
to your question and i think back to
your comments last time about the
uh the failed merger of nhia and snhu
there are there are lots of academic
questions
so um i appreciate the notion that we
would like to be supported through this
financially
but i also want you to think about other
ways that we can support people
as they try to do the work um
and and maybe i'll i'll make a
distinction in talking with
representative heath we talked about
a study maybe study isn't the right word
for it maybe the word for it
is planning give us the opportunity
to plan this out so that where
you know we we can see where we're
moving um
frankly we haven't you know terribly
involved
all of the constituencies in this
conversation
faculty and staff in the community
college system are aware of this
our students are aware of it they don't
really know what it means they're just
are large groups of people that we're
going to need to
bring along with us we we did um
post on our portal we we gave folks an
opportunity
to comment to us and then i i we asked
for um an
external uh communications agency uh
cookson communications
to take all the feedback that we got and
to organize it in a
you know in an objective way so that we
could see what
uh employees were thinking about but you
know there there are
there are huge academic concerns here
there are
huge administrative concerns um there
are just some
you know interesting differences as
we've been doing the synergies work uh
this last meeting we were talking about
the opportunities
for merging insurance it turns out that
both um
systems are using uh one particular
um i don't know a vendor i guess i would
call
to identify uh different insurance plans
for us and
we started to have a conversation about
auto insurance you know
the community college system is smaller
uh than
than usnh and we thought well maybe we
could save some money
on auto insurance it turns out that we
have a better rate
because the only people who drive ccs
and h vehicles
are employees whereas the university
rightfully has a need for students to
drive
and so i guess we've experienced what
every family does
when those teenagers move into their 20s
and your rates go down
there are conversations for us to have
that are that minute
there are much more important
conversations about
you know what the pathways are for
students
going through for liberal arts degrees
or or technical degrees but
uh representative mario you're right
there's there's a lot here and i and i
do hope
that we can create a way so that we can
look at a plan
i would suggest that we look at what the
state of maine has done and we certainly
have
opportunities from what vermont is doing
in in 2015
maine created what they called the maine
higher
education coordinating council
and it's a very small group it is the
chancellor's
um it's the chancellor of the university
of maine system and the board chair
it is the uh the president of the
community college system
and his board chair and it is the the
admiral
of the maine maritime academy and and
and their legislature charged them
with figuring out some of the things
that we've been talking about
how to make school more affordable how
to improve transfer
opportunities how to take advantage of
collaboration
to reduce administrative costs and and
they write
on a regular basis to their legislature
um and to me that's a plan you know will
they
the the very last thing on their list of
responsibilities is looking at where
they could merge
uh their systems to gain more financial
and academic opportunity you know that's
an opportunity for us
to be moving in that direction
to joe's exact point this takes years
you know we're talking about possibly as
long as a decade to figure this out
now if if we take advantage of
the opportunity to look at other people
we may be able to
accomplish this in a shorter period of
time but we're dealing with two very
complex systems representative murray
just had two more points but
kathy you wanted to no i just wanted to
mention
kind of tight tie it all together so
um representative murray your your
questions are spot on
but but this new this new board should
be ta
hopefully provided the resources to
actually
build a roadmap of what those work
streams are
what the timeline would be and let's not
forget that
everything has to come back to the
legislature this isn't the
the legislature's last look
at at how this is going to play out
because the
the bill requires that the new board
recommend legislation um
you may want to consider if there is if
there are
resources available to support the board
that that
roadmap come back to the legislature as
well
tying those financial academic
the the state issues that you mentioned
um and again i'll just come back to
joe's earlier point
to task the group that's going to be
required to implement
is the group that has the most skin in
the game
yeah that was one of the points i wanted
to try to emphasize
the what i see across higher ed and
outside higher ed is the most
interesting
work going on in trying to address
the profound structural change that
higher ed is going to go through is
takes place inside a unified governance
structure
i'm not saying i'm not saying that all
that structures where all parts of the
system are
under the same roof but if you look at
maine
in the university system they
they under one governance structure they
came up
with a plan for single accreditation for
the whole system
which will pay off in
ways they they're not even anticipating
yet when you start thinking about
sharing courses and sharing programs
they couldn't have done that if they
were separated
governance structures now that doesn't
involve the community college system i'm
just trying to make the point
if you look at the innovation taking
place in pennsylvania right now
in their state college system not their
university system it's 14 institutions
and they're doing some very interesting
and creative integration
but it's within the umbrella of a
unified governance structure the people
with the skin in the game
that's that was one point i wanted to
try to emphasize and commissions
that cut across governance structures
tend to do a lot of talking
and a lot of a lot of white papers but
the hard work's got to be done inside
governance
the other point you raised which
was the unfunded pension liability
and boy um you know that's a that's a
ticking time bomb
with no plan right now to defuse it um
you know if you look at this from uh
from the usnh perspective we've worked
really hard to build and preserve our
balance sheet and our endowment and
merging that endowment with that
unfunded pension liability immediately
hurts our bond rating um
and uh the stake could help a lot
in um helping that new board think
through
how to um essentially
diffuse that time bomb and it could take
any number of forms
but there needs to be a plan for that
quickly
and possibly it's something that could
be incorporated
into the enabling legislation that the
new board has
uh oh
matt you had a question or comment you
chairman berger just wanted to build on
on what joe and kathy just
mentioned and try to reorient this
conversation to what
house bill 2 is introduce actually seeks
to do
and i appreciate the level of granular
detail this conversation has gone on to
but what hb2 does as introduced is set a
directional path
to allow the new unified board to dive
into these issues and figure out what
that roadmap looks like
is it a two year five year or ten plan
to fully consolidate
you know some of these different systems
together whether it be
you know the staffing or the i.t or
anything else
we know that's not going to happen
overnight or in the next six months
but what hb2 asks the legislature to
endorse
is a directional pathway to put this new
unified structure
into place and empower them to make
those decisions
over whatever time horizon that new
board identifies
and again i don't want to try to solve
80 different issues
in the next two weeks because that's
certainly not the intention of hp2
and it's something definitely better
situated with this new unified board
thank you representative heath you have
a
question yes thank you um again um
just after listening to everybody i feel
um
more actually more concerned
without a definitive charge to this new
board
we have a synergies group that's already
working
and they've already taken some steps and
some things have already
been defined but now we're saying we're
going to establish
a new chancellor a whole new board
um without
the the this kind of loose direction
in hb2
without the the the tools and
and um direction that i really feel like
a brand new board with a brand new
chancellor
needs to have i think if we could take
more time
and maybe synergy's group or the higher
ed
um group could come up with a
better idea of what needs to happen
and then to look at the funding
resources i mean when i
i think about the the work that needs to
be involved
in something like this not to provide
more
resources is just um it's just like
asking you to do something
and giving you less resources to go
forward with
double the work that you have to do so
that's basically
my concern and question but i just feel
like we
need to do better diligence um
going into this and give the new board
the effective information they need
the tools with when with which to work
um
because i agree i really think we need
to do something
we desperately need to do something but
i don't want to
jump into the water in the deep end and
not know how to swim
okay thank you uh representative murray
thank you madam chair um
in order in moving i mean this is a
tough budget year you all know that
we all we're all suffering through that
and um
i also am certainly leaning towards
providing
appropriate and adequate funding for the
systems as they are now and also
resources for going forward
in order to get there i think in some
people's mind
it may be helpful to know
basically what the return on investment
would be that you know sometimes you
need to put up a little money in front
in order to get those savings later on
or you need to put up that money in
front to avoid some kind of crisis later
on
and that's fine to say in the abstract
um but could you speak to a narrative
that
um you know support i'm just you know
we're i have no idea what we're going to
be doing here with
division two but i'm just trying to
think forward a little bit
um if we seem to be leaning or wanting
to go down this path
how how would you sell it in terms of in
terms basically in terms of finance if
that's not putting too bald uh
phrase on it
well the the um
i see susan and kathy went on mute so i
figure
uh i'll i'll take a stab and then kathy
and susan says
kathy you can bail me out after i
completely mess up the answer
um if if you look at um
how we're doing the restructuring at
usnh
um we hired an outside
uh firm that has expertise in higher ed
the huron group
uh which has done a lot of restructuring
across the country
i think their latest engagement was in
wisconsin
um and uh you know the board really
insisted on getting that outside help
and and kathy
hired huron and took quite a bit of heat
for it because it was a
little more than a half million dollars
but they
they provided the um the road map
for us to get to that 10 savings without
this is the key point without um
undermining our ability to deliver our
education mission at our four
institutions
and so that return is going to be
something like for
six hundred thousand dollars a return of
70 million a year for a long time
um you can't so
so it would be it's
it's easy to cut and do damage it's
it's how do you do this intelligently
over a
multiple year period with road maps that
have been thought through
carefully and you and that avoid all of
the
very real pitfalls that susan has
discussed earlier that other
that other states have stepped right
into
there's some good stuff going on in
other states and there's some stupid
stuff
and we want to know all of it and we're
going to have to pay people to help us
do that
i say we and what i really mean is the
newborn
we'll see who's on the board so i'll
just follow up
full disclosure community college system
and the university system have put in a
joint fiscal note
relative to this um this piece of house
bill 2.
and we estimate that over the biennium
we'll need a million to a million and a
half dollars
in external support and and frankly if
if it were my wish it would all come in
year one
non-lapsing um and
what i base that on is that it what we
base that on
admittedly it's a bit of a swag but i
had conversations with huron
susan and i talked to michael thomas the
director of the new england board of
higher ed this week to understand
what what has happened in and that what
costs have been incurred in vermont and
in connecticut
i will also say that these are costs
we're estimating to provide the road
help this board provide the road map the
planning the work streams
that's not necessarily implementation
and
i guess um representative murray on the
roi
my fear is within five years we will be
just crushed to a point that
we will both have a very hard time
sustaining the work the good work that
we all do now
knowing all those challenges that joe
went over
at the beginning of of the presentation
do i have a number for you no
but but um the state will not be able to
support
the drastic reduction in revenue
that the university system and the
community college system
will sustain over the next decade with
the headwinds that we're moving into
follow-up
um just again i mean these are just very
speculative
is it hyperbolic to say that the
university system and the community
college system would disappear
um or become so i mean
i don't even mean you know disappear
entirely but um
basically become non-viable institutions
don't think they would look like they
look like now
there's several several institutions
would not survive
you can't take 30 percent of revenue out
25 percent of revenue out and expect
everybody to survive unless you've
really thought this through
thank you go ahead
susan all right
one of one of the other hats that i wear
is i'm a commissioner
for uh the new england higher ed
commission
and every uh meeting we begin with what
i refer to as the wake and funeral
and this is where private institutions
come forward
and have reached the end of their uh
their life and they they come forward
with
um what now feel like very hopeless
plans they're going to by some miracle
increase their student enrollment uh 20
um and they've identified two huge
donors
and then at the next meeting we hear
that well that didn't quite
work out for them so i i certainly
hear that we need to change
and i think we we all agree on that but
we don't agree on
the path i mean when i read hb2 and i am
so far out of my league and
understanding and thank you for the work
that you do because it's
so highly detailed just a little
experience i've had in the last six
months with this
uh has been uh overwhelming at times but
how do we institute or constitute a
board
uh you know july 1 the the the statute
takes effect by august 30th we have a
board
by november that board is supposed to
talk about the revision of the statutes
and then in january they're going to
begin to look for
a chancellor which is you know at least
a year-long process
no place in here am i hearing what the
vision is
other than we're going to save money so
i want us to think about how this
happens what's
what's a reasonable way for this to
happen that preserves
the urgency that people are seeing and
that i agree with
but that still allows us to continue
doing business um
it's it's a real challenge right now for
our colleges to be thinking in terms of
strategic planning when they don't
really even know
if they're going to exist for the next
couple of years
so what is it that you as our
legislative body can do
so that we keep moving forward but we we
work on this
idea as well rather than
what right now feels like a total
upending
of the work we do as of july 1.
okay are there any other
questions comments
okay um this has been a
extremely informative
session and
we will um
obviously as division two
we'll um be talking about this
one day next week it'll probably be
wednesday or thursday i'm not you know
i'm not sure
we're just out there as hb1 hp2
and um i think that
that all of us have a lot of stuff to
uh to think about and
um
i think that hopefully as we are
as we are thinking about this
we take we take our blinders off if
that's the right term
so that we can you know think out of the
box
and it may be you know i'm just
just talking you know
there may be a different way to
get this to move forward
without ending up
with nothing happening
and that too many times
uh we've seen this happen you know the
difference in private industry
is you know a company buys somebody out
and they merge okay
well neither the community college
system
nor the universe university system is
buying somebody
out you know your work or an education
system
and so um
mergers go on all the time
uh two companies that have totally
different cultures
totally different missions in some in
many cases
uh you know company a has nothing to do
on monday so they go
snooping around to see who they can can
pick up
and i i know that happens but
it's it's once
you know we just need to i get i
i guess i'm just saying we just need to
move forward
and i i think that
if the if the truth were known if we
want to say
something like uh you know if it doesn't
work out
in three years we go back to where we
were
i mean there's we have all kinds of
latitude
in in hb2 as i think all of you know
and that um you know we're
we're not uh we're not
uh what do you want to say
we're not at in a in a position where
we can't make recommendations we can't i
shouldn't say recommendations
changes you know we have that
uh we have that authority
but i i don't want us to get stuck
in this in this thing that says well we
need to plan
for three years because
if the if the group
that's doing the planning isn't in
charge of the results
nothing gets done that's just my
my personal uh personal feeling
and so i just ask that we
think about this and by the way i
understand
where all of you are coming from
and i know that um this sort of
[Music]
institutional change if that's the right
term
is always always extremely difficult
now i cannot guarantee
to the community college you know that
you will be
feel over time that you would be
swallowed up
but i would hope that whoever
is selected and oh by the way
we i don't think in the legislation it
says
these are new terms but i think we need
to make them new terms
so that if you know if joe
is selected to be on the um
from unh that he starts a new term he
doesn't try to
you know i don't know where he is in his
current term but
we've got to give this in my opinion
this newborn
some longevity and
you know and and synergy to work
together
and not not have joe's
term run out in a year or two years
and that's not in the legislation
okay so anyhow these are just some
random thoughts
that we will be discussing as we
move forward with this um
wednesday or thursday of next week
uh representative flynn
thank you madam chair i i guess i i just
want to sort of
reinforce uh that my you know what
what you just said i think my view is is
uh
really it does seem to me that
this the idea of
of this kind of a merger just
fundamentally makes sense
in light of the the
you know the numbers of students and the
the challenges that have been
have been put forward and you know in
that i completely understand that that
is
that that's going to make a lot of
people very nervous
and and honestly i think if we were
going to be completely honest about it
we have to
say that we that we recognize that and
that you know
and that the reality is that probably
some of them have things to be nervous
about
i mean you know it may it may well be
and i'm not saying that this is
something that would be
would be happening under the specific
you know under the specific proposal
here but it may well be
that you know 10 years from now maybe
there aren't going to be seven community
colleges around the state
or maybe there isn't going to be a keene
state or a plymouth state maybe our
maybe the university
system is going to have to be cut back
uh in some way and if that's what
makes sense then you know we i i think
we have to be very careful that we not
turn
what is proposed here into something
like
you know the base closure commission
where
you know the nobody no no uh
no elected representative wants to be
involved in
in anything other than a yes and a yes
or no vote at the end
because they don't want to be the ones
that say well
you know maybe it's actually true that
the portsmouth naval shipyard
is not really as important as nine other
as nine other uh bases around the
country i could
completely understand why if i was a
senator i wouldn't want to be the one
saying that
but it may be in fact that it's true and
so i
i i think the points you make uh madam
chairman are
are very very important and i agree with
them wholeheartedly
thank you representative porter
thank you madam chair and maybe i'm
speaking a little out of turn here but
i'm speaking as a
former public school teacher and i'm
listening to this
um and thinking of the students involved
and i'm and i am concerned
i love four-year colleges
i love the students who go there i love
two-year colleges i love the
students who go there once upon a time
local high schools
offered academic subjects but they also
offered
trade subjects within the building
because they were
there were students who wanted those
there were students who just wanted to
try them out
and they were there and then
those disappeared and we went to a
technical
school hub kind of thing
that essentially eliminated the kids
that wanted to just dabble and try them
out um
and i think we lost something in that i
think we lost something i think the
students lost something
i'm really concerned
with what uh susan hurt said
that eventually in this kind of merger
we're going to lose those students again
we're going to lose those students
who aren't academic students
[Music]
and i'm really worried about that and i
just want to
put it out there i know it's this is
getting down personal but
i understand why people might want to do
it but we're not dealing with widgets
and we're not dealing with
you know vacuum cleaners we're dealing
with young people
and middle-aged people and their minds
and their
in their uh their livelihoods and their
futures and
it's a big concern to me okay
thank you very much and uh if there's
uh i don't see anybody else's hand up
so um we will uh close our meeting
today and um
if you think this is a challenge wait
till monday
when we when we start talking about the
scholarship program
so um you know this one is easy compared
to whatever is going to happen on monday
and um then
one day this week i'm not sure which it
is we have to deal with
um the uh
issue of uh
setting up a commission for discipline
of
police officers you know so
we've got our hands full this next week
um fortunately most of the things on the
um
you know on the budget side we're in
we're in pretty good shape but we still
have some
pretty sticky issues in hb2 that we need
to
we need to think about and
uh let me also say that
there was some uh questions about when
amendments can be submitted uh
for hb2 and um
that action can you know take place
because we'll be you know i
i would like if we could to handle the
amendments
as we are talking about
the subject so if we get them prepared
then whatever the subject might be
we'll have the amendments
that that go along with uh with that
particular section
so i guess i will see you all on monday
at uh at 10 o'clock well i won't see all
of you but
i'll see the representatives and um
we will let you know um
which day we're going to be um
trying to come to grips with what's
going on with this particular section of
hb2
so that you're not uh somebody is you
know you can have somebody at the
meeting and
um if you want to talk you can talk if
you don't
that's okay too but uh but this you know
i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna put us in this little you
know this little box
uh because although we uh although we
get to
make the final decision uh we're not
uh we all live in glass houses i'll put
it that way
so whatever we need to do anyhow so
listen have a
have a good weekend and um
we'll see you all on monday take care
thank you